and in washington president trump's
attempts to hold on to power are driving
a wedge
into and possibly through the republican
party there is a widening rift
between lawmakers over a plan to
challenge the electoral college vote
tomorrow normally a day of pop and
ceremony nancy cordes
has been covering all of it on capitol
hill for us nancy good morning to you
good morning intentions are definitely
rising ahead of this
certification clash tomorrow one of the
leaders
of the challenge effort missouri's josh
hawley says that protesters
showed up at his virginia home and
threatened his family
protest organizers deny that that
happened
and so clearly there's a lot of drama
surrounding a process that's normally
a formality this is about the integrity
of our elections
missouri senator josh hawley cheered on
a growing movement last night
republicans who plan to contest the
results tomorrow
without evidence of fraud i believe
there are serious questions with respect
to the presidential election despite
attempts by senate leader mitch
mcconnell to talk them out of it
at least 13 gop senators have joined the
cause
including georgia's kelly lefler who
spoke last night at a rally with the
president on the eve of her special
election
i will object to the electoral college
vote
the effort has dismayed some republicans
like
ohio's rob portman who noted that not a
single state
found evidence of fraud or
irregularities widespread enough to
change the result of the election
another republican west virginia's
shelly moore capito
warned that refusing to count a state's
electoral votes
in the absence of such evidence would
disenfranchise
millions of american voters kevin cramer
of north dakota
agreed i come from a red small state i
don't want to have
our votes overturned by other members of
congress from other places i don't see
in the constitution
where we even actually have that
authority quite honestly but president
trump
slammed republicans like him yesterday
dubbing them
the surrender caucus people will
remember the people that don't support
us
he even upped the pressure on his own
vice president
who will preside over tomorrow's joint
session of congress
i hope that our great vice president
our great vice president comes through
for us he's a great guy
of course if he doesn't come through i
won't like him quite as much
mr pence made it clear he won't
disappoint
we'll have our day in congress we'll
hear the objections
we'll hear the evidence but vice
president-elect
kamala harris argued none of it will
change the outcome
let me just tell you something we're
going to be inaugurated
here in washington more than 300
national guard members have now been
activated ahead of expected pro-trump
rallies tomorrow and all d.c police
officers
will be on duty as well because they're
anticipating
tens of thousands of people in the
streets anthony
nancy thank you